Clocking in at 5 minutes and 55 seconds long
and encompassing elements of hard rock, opera
and pop, Bohemian Rhapsody is certainly one
of the more eclectic songs to make it into
the charts, but it’s by no means the longest.
Hey Jude by The Beatles (7:11), I’d Do Anything
for Love (But I Won’t Do That) by Meatloaf
(7:58) and All Around The World by Oasis (9:38)
are all songs that have managed to squeak
their way into the charts despite being about
twice the length of most other pop songs.
That said, the fact that there are so few
songs over 5 minutes in length that have gained
that much airtime is a testament to how rare
of an occurrence that actually is.
Taken from the album A Night at the Opera
and credited solely to Freddie Mercury, Bohemian
Rhapsody is noted as being one of the most
lavishly expensive songs ever recorded.
In fact, it was reportedly the most expensive
single ever at the time.
This was, in part, due to the band ultimately
using 180 separate overdubs, which was incredibly
tricky to do given that they were working
with 24-track analogue tape.
There was also the fact that Mercury wasn’t
exactly sure how the song was supposed to
go.
Queen’s producer and a close friend of Mercury,
Roy Baker, would later note that the opera
section of the song ended up sounding nothing
like Mercury’s original concept because
they “kept changing and adding things to
it.”
He also noted that when Mercury first introduced
him to the idea of the song, “He played
the beginning on the piano, then stopped and
said, ‘And this is where the opera section
comes in!’
Then we went out to eat dinner.”
Initially, Baker set aside a 30 second strip
of tape for the opera section, but had to
resort to cutting and adding new pieces of
tape to the reel due to Mercury’s habit
of “adding another Galileo” every time
they tried to record it.
Due to this type of thing, the opera section
on its own reportedly took almost a month
to record.
To quote Baker a final time on why this was
a big deal: “in 1975 [that] was the average
time spent on a whole album”.
Although today the song has been lauded as
a masterpiece, when recording wrapped on Bohemian
Rhapsody, EMI (Queen’s record label at the
time) didn’t rate it that highly with their
general manager of international sales going
as far to say “what the f*ck is this?”
the first time the band played him the song.
EMI wasn’t alone in this thinking and almost
everyone the band played an advanced copy
of the song for said the same thing, including
Elton John who famous exclaimed “are you
f*cking mad?”
upon first hearing the song and being told
it was going to be the first single of A Night
at the Opera.
As it turns out, EMI had banked on You’re
My Best Friend, being the big hit of the album
and they pushed the band to make it the first
single.
Queen remained steadfast in their decision
and told EMI that the first single had to
be Bohemian Rhapsody.
In response, EMI tried to meet the band in
the middle and suggest that they trim the
song down, a suggestion that the band quickly
dismissed.
The one person who saw the genius of the song,
other than the band of course, was famed DJ
and a close friend of Mercury, Kenny Everett,
who famously stated that it was “going to
be number one for centuries.”
Exactly how Everett first got hold of a copy
of the single early in October of 1975 isn’t
clear.
Depending on who you want to believe, Everett
either asked Roy Baker for a copy after hearing
it at a private demonstration or was sent
one by Mercury himself shortly after it was
recorded.
Either way, we know that Everett was asked
to kindly keep the record to himself and absolutely
not play it on the radio or talk about how
he’d gotten his hands on a hot new record
live on air.
According to Baker, Everett got the message
with Baker stating he said, “I won’t play
it”, while giving them a wink.
You see, the band was still struggling to
get their label to make it the first single
of the album, so took matters into their own
hands.
Despite the “strict” instructions not
to play it, immediately after getting a copy
of the single, Everett began playing clips
of the song on his morning show on Capital
FM, a popular London based radio station.
Each time Everett aired a clip from the song,
he’d play it off as an accident, telling
listeners that “his finger must’ve slipped”
and that they weren’t supposed to have heard
anything.
Steadily, interest in the song grew.
Callers began flooding the station with requests,
begging Everett to play the whole song, which
he’d by this point built up to a ridiculous
degree, telling his now captive audience that
he couldn’t play the entire song because
he’d been made to promise that he wouldn’t.
Eventually, Everett relented and played the
entire song 14 times over the course of two
days.
One critical thing Everett left out about
the single was where fans could buy it, causing
the station to be visited by hundreds of curious
music fans hoping to acquire a copy.
Record stores across the country were also
similarly surprised when demands began pouring
in for the single the following Monday morning
after Everett had played the full song.
The problem was that at this point the song
hadn’t actually been released yet.
A similar thing was happening on the other
side of the pond when Paul Drew of RKO managed
to wrangle a copy of the song from somewhere
and started playing it across the RKO network
of stations.
As Baker later stated, “It was a strange
situation where radio on both sides of the
Atlantic was breaking a record that the record
companies said would never get airplay!”
With the song already something of a hit on
the radio even before being released, the
label relented and on the 31st of October,
1975, Bohemian Rhapsody was officially released
as a single in the UK where it spent 9 weeks
at number one.
In keeping with Kenny’s predictions, the
song is regarded today as one of the finest
ever recorded, including being inducted into
the Grammy Hall of Fame in 2004.